il s'agit probablement de la découverte
de sa carrière épaulé par d'autres
confrères
l'archéologue français pierre malinowski
a mis fin il ya quelques mois un mystère
long de 200 ans lors de fouilles l'année
passée à smolensk dans l'ouest de la
russie
il découvre le squelette du général
gudin un proche de napoléon le chercheur
raconte l'histoire d'une découverte
stupéfiante connaissons napoléon était
quand même narcissique si c'était un de
ses meilleurs amis il la vit son rôle
plus hauts de la ville on a fait un
premier essai avec les archéologues au
mois de mai échec
il y avait rien il était pâle ramé
français sont repartis et là je me suis
retrouvé tout seul et je me suis dit bon
bah je continue ou pas parce que ça va
être compliqué je me suis rendu en
juillet donc deux mois après sur place
et j'ai vu dans la forteresse de
smolensk il y avait une espèce de grand
but qui était d'époque qu'avait moins
300 400 enquêtait été construites au
xviie siècle par les polonais je me suis
dit je vois bien une génération 7 buts
là parce que napoléon
si l'endroit le plus haut on est quoi
faire des fûts l'air et pour mettre
toute la garde autour et je le dis ça
peut être là et il s'est vraiment à
leurs prêts on a bien vers les coups de
pelle et là on a tapé un crabe et là
j'ai compris tout de suite que c'était
lui pour identifier le squelette pierre
malinowski dispose d'un indice de taille
si c'est lui vous allez le voir sur sa
jambe qui a été arraché par un boulet de
canon
sylla au niveau du tibia règle à l'agent
d'exploser il ya une chance sur un
million que ça soit pas lui et on
arrivait sur la jambe directement
janvier des fractures et les budgets la
jambe arraché haut du jour s'en suit
alors le rapatriement de certains
ossements du général gudin en france
donnant lieu à une scène cocasse
donc moi ce que j'ai fait c'est que j'ai
récupéré la jambe du général les dents
elle crache des prix dans mon sac dans
l'avion et chantre en france avec sa wii
et paralympiques le spécial parce qu'il
n'ya pas de lois qui existent entre les
deux pays
pour ça on a fait les analyses adn en
france qui ont été posées par deux
la police criminelle de marseille qui
ont donné les résultats le titre vent et
d'un cent pour cent adn nucléaire
confirmé voilà des fouilles
archéologiques rocambolesque qui
emmenait à la résolution d'une énigme
historique concernant l'un des plus
vaillants compagnon de napoléon
[Musique]